hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well for the purposes
of understanding the points that air is
making in Chapter one of language truth
and logic where he's introducing some of
his key ideas it's useful to follow out
a distinction that he's making and I
have to point out he's making this in
kind of a loose way that as you go
further into the book you see that some
of these terms may not fit perfectly but
it works well enough for understanding
the examples that he brings up and the
general points that that he wants to to
make so he's going to talk about
empirical he calls them hypotheses
although he also uses experiential
statements and propositions more or less
synonymously with that we'll see exactly
how they fit in it in a moment and then
he talks about tautologies and strictly
speaking of tautology is is somewhat of
a narrow thing but we're going to talk
about how this fits in and then this big
category of nonsense and and why does he
bring this up well one main thrust of
this entire work is to say that much of
what we call philosophy is
actually nonsense and we should confine
ourselves to a much smaller ambit or
scope when it comes to what we're doing
in philosophy that which we can
successfully analyze primarily
linguistically but you know also in
terms of harnessing the natural or
social sciences or everyday observation
and it's it's essentially as he says an
empiricist project so it harkens back to
David Hume in particular but the
empiricists were also you know before
Hume and had a similar project of
reducing everything as much as possible
to statements of experience and the idea
is that whatever it is that we're
thinking about we can call them concepts
ideas we can look at it linguistically
in terms of propositions these are all
ultimately either referencing experience
which is the basic building blocks or
raw content out of we out of which we
build things or they have to do with
things that are non experiential like
for example laws of logic or principles
of logic or operations if you like or
the very ways in which our language is
arranged and the way our language works
what we can call logical grammar to take
a term from Vidkun stein right and so if
that's the case then we can eliminate a
lot this is quite similar to what Hume
in the treatise and the very famous
passage that gives rise to what people
call Humes Fork right he says matters of
fact empirical propositions or
hypotheses or relations of ideas if it's
not either one of those then cast it in
the flames for it can contain nothing
but sophistry right and that would be
the nonsense that we're talking about
here
so let's now that we've had a little bit
of history lesson let's talk about
what the difference is between these my
air thinks this is an important set of
distinctions so empirical statements or
the term that he uses in Chapter one is
primarily hypotheses our propositions
that can be true or false so we don't
actually know in many cases whether they
are true or false but they have to be
either true or false and if they're
empirical then they could be one or they
could be the other if you say well they
can only be true then it's not an
empirical proposition right
an empirical proposition is something
that you would look to to verify through
experience in some way as being true or
false
it's held you could say in suspension
between these two polarities until
you've decided it and even when it's
true it's possible in some other
conceivable situation or world that it
could be in fact false so an empirical
proposition might be something like I am
49 years old at this point in time which
happens to be a true proposition right
now but give it a year and it's a false
one or go backwards in time another year
and it becomes a false one all right
there are other things which are less
liable to be eroded by time Milwaukee is
a city in Wisconsin true now wasn't true
around say 1600 or so and it may not be
true in the future you know perhaps
it'll change in some way by nothing
being here or perhaps will not call it
Milwaukee will actually call it after
the parlance of those who live here
Milwaukee right and we'll rewrite it as
mwa uke or something like that you know
that's possible to say that something
changed and went from being true to
false so that's empirical propositions
to autologous propositions are always
going to be true and there's actually a
you know sort of correspondent to this
in
propositions that would always be false
as well there's nothing empirically that
could make them true they haven't always
be false a great example of that is one
plus one equals three that's you know
unless you're doing some weird
linguistic sleight of hand that's just
not going to be the case right so
propositions that can only be true and
we might actually say sets of
propositions that can only be true as
well because many things that are taught
ologists it's because of the ways that
they're arranged in relation to each
other then we have nonsense Ayer says
that nonsense is strictly speaking
pseudo propositions pseudo strictly
speaking means false but they can't
actually be false so we have to
understand well actually pseudos
technically speaking in Greek means lie
pseudos right lying propositions they're
not actually lying propositions because
if they were they'd be empirical instead
they're you could say they're lying in a
certain sense about themselves in
asserting that they actually are
propositions in the same sense empirical
propositions are because they're neither
true nor false and they're not true
neither true nor false just because we
don't know or because they're somehow
wavering between them but rather because
there's no way in which they could be
true or false now notice the difference
between nonsense and two autologous
propositions two autologous propositions
there's no circumstances under which we
could falsify them but they're still
true nonsense can be neither verified
nor falsified there's just nothing there
to work with in terms of empirical sense
or in terms of what we might call
logical structure so again let's let's
go back through this what are the
empirical propositions include all
hypotheses that can be verified by
experience or observation I am wearing a
tie right now this tie belongs to me hmm
is that an empirical proposition I don't
have like a deed of title of this tie
nor
I have a receipt but I think you can say
that it actually is an empirical
proposition you could ask around and get
enough people to say yeah that's that's
that guy's tie and it would fit there
you know there's nothing in the you know
logical necessity of things or even the
way in which we understand property to
make it automatically be my tie and you
know part of the evidence of this is
that I could donate this tied a good
will or raffle it off to my viewers or
listeners or something like that right
and alienate this tie from myself but it
is something that could be verified and
we could go on and on and on you know
there's grass in the park right now even
under the snow now notice there's that's
a little bit of a complex proposition
I'm asserting that there is no which
happens to be true right now but won't
be true most of the year and I'm also
asserting that underneath that snow
there is grass so there's there is snow
and there is grass which happens to be
true most of the year but it's not a
tautology statement the city could come
through in the park and rip all the
grass up or we could have a terrible
drought here or you know who knows a
fire and then the grass would be go on
so all hypotheses that can be verified
by experience or observation are what we
call empirical or experiential
autologous would include all the
necessarily true propositions for
example or for example those of
mathematics like one plus one equals two
or things that were able to prove as
theorems think about the Pythagorean
theorem or statements we're sticking
with really basic stuff here like you
know within a triangle the angles add up
to the sum of two right angles which is
180 degrees how the ancients and the
medieval and early modern thought of it
even within non Euclidean geometry where
a triangle could have more than 180 or
less than 180 degrees there's still like
a system of rules that you're working
with in a
structure and here's where logic and
language actually come together right
these are often what whatare will call
analytic propositions meaning that
they're not made true by experience in
any way they are functions of the way in
which logic or language works and error
I think thinks that mathematics is
essentially an outgrowth of logic so
they could be linguistic like a bachelor
is an unmarried male that's to otologist
there's no circumstances under which
that statement would ever be false right
it can't be falsified and because it
can't be falsified it really can't be
verified either it just simply is
nonsense includes and this is one main
part of what this book is about
especially in the later chapters
everything that air would call
metaphysical all metaphysics is in
essence nonsense
according to air ethical propositions
insofar as they're actually part of the
ethics turn out to be nonsense as well
at least in a factual sense they they
can convey something emotional aesthetic
religious statements as well non
verifiable not to autologous they
strictly speaking on a factual level
don't signify anything so empirical
statements talk about the observe of the
observable or empirical world or they
could talk about our inner experience I
could say I am remembering the smell of
a cinnamon bun right now right could be
true or false depending on whether I am
in fact remembering that you can't look
inside my head and see whether I am
there are some statements like that or
you know if I say I am in pain
presumably that's still an empirical
statement although it can't be verified
by you to otologist statements don't
actually talk about the empirical world
even though they may have components
that seem to be talking about
miracle world they're not actually about
the empirical world and then finally
nonsense doesn't talk about the
empirical world but it may and generally
does express feelings or emotions or
Moral Sentiments all sorts of other
things there is one other thing that I
do want to point out and this is towards
the end of chapter one err says that he
might be thought to be saying that
metaphysics is merely poetry or a
literature and he says the view that the
meta position is to be reckoned among
the poets rests on an assumption that
both talked nonsense but this assumption
is false so we have to be careful with
like a static or some other languages in
the vast majority of cases the sentences
which are produced by poets do have
literal meaning right and put aside
nonsense things like you know Lewis
Carroll's Jabberwocky you know twas
brillig and the slithy Toves did gyre
and gimble in the way nobody knows what
the hell any of that means although it's
very suggestive right but if I say
something like you know the little the
the the box is in the little red wagon
and you know that's why things are so
screwed up those those things actually
have literal meaning they could be false
and as a matter of fact eco sodomy says
that many literary works are largely
composed of falsehoods but this does not
mean that they are composed of pseudo
propositions it's really only when they
start to become metaphysical that or
start to make all sorts of ethical
claims that we're dealing with pseudo
propositions on the part of the literary
authors right whether it's poetry or
prose or what-have-you
so this is an important set of
distinctions the one last thing I do
want to say is we know when we strictly
speaking a tautology is going to be you
know a proposition or set of
propositions that must be true because
of their logical structure and we don't
want to think just in terms of single
statements but we could also think of
frameworks as as well so that's that's
important to think of going forward and
that connects us back to
you know Hume and talking about you know
matters of fact and relations of ideas
relations of ideas could encompass many
many ideas but there's no connection to
empirical observation or facts in that
case so this is what air is working with
here in chapter one
you